faire de la pédagogie autour de la
prochaine réforme l'objectif de cette
réunion publique à vélizy avec jean paul
delevoye haut-commissaire aux retraites
le nouveau système des retraites par
répartition sera universel et par point
avec la fin des 42 régimes spéciaux
d'autres principes sont encore en débat
quand on est dans l'universalité des
droits c'est les mêmes règles pour tous
un métier identique retraite identique
et tout ce qui ne justifie pas une
spécificité une particularité comme les
artisans les commerçants les professions
libérales ou les professions régaliennes
qui assurent notre sécurité
tout cela intégrera le régime universel
ça c'est un vrai débat vous savez entre
l'âge de déquilibre que j'ai proposé et
celles et ceux qui souhaiteraient une
durée de cotisation individuelle
c'est en cours de débat ceci sera
tranchée d'ici la fin de l'année près
d'une centaine de personnes présentes
pour cette soirée ils ont pu poser des
questions ou interpeller le haut
commissaire sur leurs inquiétudes
je n'attends pas cette réforme je crains
cette réforme on est bien d'accord
cette réforme je n'en veux pas car c'est
une réforme qui sera au tour d'une
retraite à points
le groupe modem à l'assemblée nationale
appelle à l'organisation d'une
conférence sociale dans le parisien en
ligne de mire notamment éviter un
durcissement du conflit social à partir
du 5 décembre avec un appel à une grève
illimitée face à la réforme des
retraites
je crois que tout le monde est convaincu
de l'idée qu'il faut aller au bout de la
réforme de notre système de retraite
cela passe par du dialogue par de la
concertation il va y avoir le 5 décembre
qui sera un moment d'expression je
souhaite que ça ne dégénère pas et que
ça ne devienne pas une expression de
violence mais que le dialogue domine sur
la violence et que nous puissions
collectivement porter cette réforme des
retraites en 2010 est la france comptait
près de 16,2 millions de retraités sur
la même année les dépenses allouées à ce
poste atteignent les 325 milliards
d'euros